tj osborne half of popular brother
country music duo
brothers osbourne has come out now tj
has been out to family members and
friends in nashville for years
saying i'm very comfortable being gay i
find myself being guarded for not
wanting to talk about something that i
personally
don't have a problem with tj is the only
openly gay
artist signed to a major country label
which is a monumental moment for the
genre
and the band has always been inclusive
including an lgbtq plus couple in their
video
for stay a little longer
so why did tj decide to publicly come
out well
he said i want to get to the height of
my career being completely who i am
i mean i am who i am but i've kept a
part of me muted and it's been stifling
tj is well aware that many people within
the country music community and
nashville
may not support this saying for me to
show up at an award show with a man
would be jaw-dropping to people
it wouldn't be like oh cool he added
at this point my happiness is more
valuable than anything else i'd ever be
able to achieve
tj's good friend and lgbtq plus ally
casey musgraves said this
others will now feel invited to the
country music party for the first time
country music deserves a future more
honest than its past
and some of tj's other friends within
country music have
also showed their support for the singer
on twitter this morning
including maren morris cassidy pope
bobby bones
cody allen and chris young and although
it is yet to be seen how the country
music genre
will react to tj coming out he does have
the full support of his brother
and bandmate john who said if i had to
have
all my money and success erased for my
brother to be truly fulfilled in life
i wouldn't even think about it not for a
second
love that congrats tj
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews click
subscribe or watch these videos